hi just briefly uh i noticed that a lot
of people gave me a thumbs up on this
whole food issue because i'm uh cooking
now for my wife who's
gonna be unable to stand up for quite a
while i mean she can stand up but she
has to keep her leg up so
just and for those of you who are
working on your english it might be
interesting to get some of these food
terms
so what we had tonight
was first of all i have on my way home
from the office i bought some endives
and some radicchio
so with the endives because i had some
leftover salmon from yesterday a small
amount i took that salmon
which i had done in the oven
and little mayonnaise and little
yogurt and a little
parsley and a little bit of onions
i think that was all oh and some i had a
little bit of salad dressing left over
last night i had a a salad
uh which had um
fennel in it fennel and avocado and and
lettuce and that
and uh so because it has fennel i like
having orange with that so there's a
little bit of orange juice and also some
some zest you know the orange rind had
gone into the salad dressing that i used
the night before and i still had a small
bit left over i always save every little
bit of salad dressing or whatever goes
in the fridge so i put that into the
blender blended it up and then i put
that on the the little pieces of endive
and that was like our order we always
like to have an hour before we have our
main meal we always have a little glass
of wine
then the main dish tonight i had a
a roast that we bought at costco it just
comes in a package i just put it in an
oven proof container and then it goes in
the oven period
then i uh then i also i boiled some
potatoes very quickly then threw them in
the oven so we'd have sort of like
roasted potatoes
and and then i had bought also some
asparagus so i i wrapped
um radicchio around the asparagus first
of all the asparagus i had to kind of
throw it in hot water
and and boil it and then throw it in
some ice water to kind of stop that and
so they're nice and crisp and then i
wrapped them in radicchio and i put that
in the oven with about 10 minutes to go
ah and then we pulled all of that out
and that was what we had for dinner oh
and we followed up with some delicious
cheeses uh
just to go with our wine uh we had
there's some 12 a month old manchego
and a french blue cheese scent a guy or
something other the cheese guy that i go
to he was very hot on this cheese and it
is that it is delicious blue cheese so
that's what we had and i will update you
on my food if in fact it continues to be
of interest especially for those of you
who are learning english it gives you a
different kind of vocabulary so there
you have it bye for now